prohibitive costs that the mandates in
h.r 1195 would impose on america's
hospitals
particularly on those that provide care
in rural and
underserved areas could strain scarce
resources
and jeopardize patient care
these mandates would burden health care
providers that are struggling
to maintain services during the most
deadly public health emergency
in 100 years end quote
uh madam speaker i ask unanimous consent
that the american hospital association
let her be included in the record
without objection
thank you and madam speaker you know
we're hearing from the people who are on
the front lines
and we've said we want to protect the
people on the front lines
well let's listen to the people on the
front lines
with that i reserve reserves the
gentleman
from connecticut is recognized uh thank
you madam speaker really quick on page
11 of the bill it specifically states
that the plans
proposed to be adopted by osha would be
quote tailored and specific to
conditions and hazard for the covered
facility of the covered service
including
patient specific risk factors and risk
factors specific to each work area or
unit that is not one size
fits all and with that i now yield to uh
again a member who can really bring
very powerful personal experience uh to
this issue
the gentlelady from texas ms garcia and
how much time
for uh one minute minute minute and a
half uh two minutes
a gentlewoman from texas is recognized
for two minutes
thank you madam speaker and thank you to
the congressman i am here today to
express my support for this very
important piece of legislation
this is simple it's much needed and it's
just a common sense bill
and for my friends across the aisle who
think that this is some intellectual
exercise that we're trying to find some
mandate
or that we need to listen to the front
lines while i'm here
to tell you what happens in the front
lines
well it was not yesterday it was when i
was a social worker
a geatric social worker we had received
a report of a street child taking care
of a senior
and they were concerned about the senior
and the street child
i went to the door to make an assessment
i knocked on the door
and i was greeted by a saturday night
special
right in my face as a social worker
just trying to do my job and she kept
saying you ain't going to take my baby
ain't going to take my baby
and i was scared
scared and scared never having faced a
gun to my face
madam speaker i'm sure you know what i'm
talking about because you've probably
had similar experience
but i was a social worker just trying to
make an assessment to see if this senior
needed help at home i had nothing to do
with trying to take her child away but
she confused me
for a child welfare worker this is what
can happen
it's happened to me it happens today
and as representative haley pointed out
it happened at 2 a.m this morning
not to a social worker a postal uh fedex
worker
we must do something to make sure that
we can protect workers
and that we end workplace violence
this is a small step it's not an
intellectual exercise
it's real i'm speaking personally
and i'm here to stand with social
workers across america
to make sure that we do everything we
can
to make say make their job works place
safe and that everyone is protected
thank you ma'am and i yield back
and from connecticut reserves the
gentlewoman from north carolina is
recognized
thank you madam speaker i reserve the
gentlewoman reserves the gentleman from
connecticut is recognized thank you
madam speaker it's now my honor to yield
one minute to the gentlelady from
illinois
miss schakowsky the gentlewoman from
illinois is recognized for
one minute thank you workplace violence
has reached epidemic levels and is the
third greatest cause of
job death right now nurses
medical assistants emergency responders
and social workers
face some of the greatest threats
suffering more than
72 percent of all workplace
um assaults and women suffer
two out of every three uh serious
workplace violence incidents this is
unacceptable
we need to protect workers and require
employers to put in place effective
workplace
violence prevention plans it's simple
make a plan we need to protect our
health care and social
service workers who have done so much
for us
during the pandemic to care for us and
now we need to care for them
we need hr 1195 now let's come together
and get it done and i would ask uh
unanimous consent to put
into the record a um
it's a editorial column from
bonnie castillo and also a letter
from the afl-cio
without objection the gentlewoman's time
has expired the gentleman from
connecticut reserves the gentlewoman
from north carolina is recognized
thank you madam speaker may i inquire as
to how much time is remaining
the gentlewoman from north carolina has
11 minutes and three quarters
the gentleman from connecticut has 11
minutes and one quarter
madam speaker i'll reserve the
gentlewoman from north carolina reserves
a gentleman from connecticut is
recognized
thank you madam speaker it's now my uh
privilege to yield one minute to the
gentlelady from minnesota miss craig
the gentlewoman from minnesota is
recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker just over two
months ago
a man walked into an alliana health
clinic in buffalo
minnesota and opened fire killing one
employee and injuring four others
on that tragic day nurses doctors
social workers and others were
reportedly targeted because
of their professions tragically this
senseless
and horrific act of violence is
representative of a broader trend in our
society
today members of the health care
workforce are five
times as likely to suffer a workplace
injury than americans in other
professions
madam speaker what in the hell are we
doing
in congress if we're not going to stand
up and do
anything for our health care heroes and
those
workers my colleagues who vote against
this bill
are ignoring the pleas of the emts and
the emergency workers and
all of those folks who have been on the
front lines of this health care
pandemic
happy to yield the lady 15 seconds
additional 15 seconds it is our
responsibility to step forward and help
protect
our workers it is beyond the pale to put
our heads in the sand
as members of congress and say there is
nothing that we can do
what the hell are we doing here if we do
that and i yield back
the gentlewoman yields back the
gentleman from connecticut reserves the
gentlewoman from north carolina is
recognized
thank you madam speaker
madam speaker we grieve for anyone
who has killed violently in this country
under any circumstances
again that is not a partisan issue
madam speaker the healthcare industry is
currently in the midst of responding to
a once in a century pandemic
and has rightly prioritized significant
resources
to caring for patients and keeping its
employees safe from covet 19.
forcing osha to issue an interim final
standard on workplace violence within
one year
as h.r 1195 requires will have a
devastating
impact on the health care industry
during the covet 19 pandemic
last thing our health care providers
need during this unprecedented public
health crisis
are more costly mandates from washington
that will strain resources and personnel
and jeopardize patient care
moreover the biden administration is
expected
soon to impose new employer mandates in
the form of an
osha emergency temporary standard for
coping 19
and eventually a permanent infectious
disease rule which will have a
significant impact on the health care
industry
at a time when health care facilities
are experiencing massive revenue losses
and have invested significant resources
into responding to coven 19 the issuance
of two new regulations from washington
potentially within months of each other
will be devastating
our nation's health care providers have
responded
admirably to the pandemic and are doing
heroic work to keep americans safe and
healthy
the house should reject this ill-timed
and ill-advised legislation
that will inhibit this work and burden
the health care industry at exactly
the wrong time with that i reserve the
gentlewoman reserves the gentleman from
connecticut is recognized
thank you madam speaker again just to
clarify the april 9th cbo report that
came out
which again cited the the numbers which
were cited accurately by
the opposition is a number that has
spread out over 200
000 facilities across the country again
if you do the math
we're talking about nine thousand
dollars per facility
per year i mean ask yourself whether or
not
that figure you know weighing the
balance of what we're trying to
um protect here which is people's health
and lives is worth it
i i think most people you know would
apply common sense to that and realize
that um
you know that's that's not going to
drive health care costs through the roof
and in fact it's going to protect
workers and protect them from
absenteeism it's going to protect
these institutions from high workers
compensation costs i mean it's just
common sense
uh here to to join us again today and i
think her
presence here is uh uh the gentlelady
from uh michigan miss taliba yield two
minutes
the gentlewoman from michigan is
recognized for two minutes
thank you so much everyone everyone
should feel safe
at work they should be safe at work i
want to give testimony to kenya who's a
49 year old certified nursing assistant
i want to bring her words here in the
congress to understand what we're trying
to do who we're trying to protect
she said quote you don't know if you're
going to take the virus home to your
family or not
i have two children 16 and 18 and a
one-year-old grandbaby that i worry
about all the time i have a designated
place
where i take my uniform off and my shoes
off to keep my family safe
i come in i go directly to the basement
where i already have a change of clothes
strip all my clothes off
put all of my clothes directly into the
washing machine
then there's my mom i'm her only child
now
so that's a big scare because who's
going to take care of her
it's very scary for my family they don't
want me to go back to work
but i have to go to work because i have
to be able to take care of my family
and i tell them my residents need me
these are the human stories behind
the fact that people right now are
asking us the united states congress to
pass legislation
that has long overdue to protections for
workers in some of the most high
stress least appreciated positions in
our communities these workers are a
front line they are
on the front lines day in day out
serving vulnerable groups
and face rates of workplace violence out
of five times the rate of workers in
other
communities and she's expressing in here
just the number of the stress of it
and on top of that workplace violence
and i want for the submit for the right
record madam speaker if i may uh a
letter of support
from seiu on behalf of the over 1
million health care and social service
workers across our country these are
protections that should have been long
been in place and enforced i urge my
colleagues to support this legislation
and when passed and signed into law
i urge osha to immediately work for
issue the standards necessary to protect
these workers
i give that story because on top has
expired
the gentleman from connecticut
recognition yield additional 30 seconds
yeah additional 30 seconds has yielded
it i give that story of kenya
that lives in livonia michigan because
on top of all of that
she was dealing with obviously the
number of lack of protections in the
workplace
and again these are people that take
care of our loved ones take care of our
sick take care of those that are
mentally ill that need assistance that
their family members
are not equipped or trained to do the
least we can do especially during this
pandemic
is to offer them more protection and
safety in the workplace i yield
the gentlewoman yields back the
gentleman from connecticut
reserves a gentlewoman from north
carolina is recognized
thank you madam speaker i i understand
from the gentleman from connecticut that
he's prepared to close
and and i am also one from north
carolina is recognized
thank you madam speaker madam speaker
overbearing regulations
burden workers and stifle the economy
preventing workplace violence in health
care and social services settings
is crucial and we should get this done
by allowing osha to issue standards
through the normal rulemaking process
which brings
all experts and parties including small
businesses to the table
short-circuiting the process and rushing
to a conclusion
eliminates valuable technical and
scientific input
and will lead to unintended consequences
which could have a detrimental
impact on workplace safety outcomes
a bipartisan solution was possible here
but once again democrats have kicked it
to the curb
i urge a no vote on h.r 1195
and i yield back the balance of my time
the gentlewoman yields back the
gentleman from connecticut is recognized
thank you madam speaker and again i want
to thank the gentlelady
from north carolina and and here's the
good news um when we started this
journey
on this legislation back in 2013
a number of us requested a gao report
because we had heard you know anecdotal
evidence about the fact that
healthcare workers were experiencing
this you know really disturbing
level of violence that was again
something that people had really never
seen before
and gao took three years very
methodically as only they do i mean
they're the gold standard in terms of
research and they brought in all the
studies
and all the evaluation and they verified
sadly
that all the statistics that we've
talked about here on the floor
today 73 of incidents happen in these
two sectors
um the fact is is that they not only
verified that but they showed that
those numbers are actually under
reporting because what's happening out
there
is that because we don't have any system
that people can turn to
when they're experiencing this kind of
unacceptable
behavior they basically are in a
situation where most of the time they
just they're saying you know
suck it up shake it shake it off that's
part of the job just move on
don't don't don't you know spend any
time on that so
in fact what gao told us is that the
numbers are that we're seeing
in other um sort of reports under report
in fact what's going on uh out there
again we we took that report
we crafted the legislation we really did
accommodate
some of the issues that we've heard
talked about on the floor here today
about ensuring that there is going to be
an adequate comment period for all
stakeholders
i mean we want that i mean we understand
that you know the hospital association
just like the emergency room docs just
like the nurses
they all should have their opportunity
to to weigh in in terms of what is a a
a viable workable standard
and but what we don't need is to have
osha just sort of
lapse into its notorious
dysfunctional delays in terms of
developing a workforce
standard and mr scott ticked off again
some of the most recent examples 2017
beryllium
took 18 years silica dust
took 17 years and and again the last
administration when they came to the
committee they said no
we're we're going to start the process
we're going to begin you know
a docket in terms of getting uh rule
making and then the first
schedule date was delayed and then the
second scheduled date was delayed again
and and on and on and on and right now
today as we stand here in this
in this chamber there is nothing
scheduled right now
and really when you really boil down
where i think the disagreement exists
and i'm
you know happy to acknowledge that but i
think it's a meaningful
distinction which is that we're gonna
put this agency on the clock
we're telling them that you know you can
you you you know
follow the procedures take the the
comment
but we're not going to sit back and
allow this
unacceptable trend to continue
unaddressed
you know that agency was created back in
the nixon administration to protect
america's workers
and you know what it's your it's and we
want you as the as the
branch of government that created you to
to
to develop a standard in a reasonable
amount of time and madam speaker
i just wanna this is not unprecedented
congresses in the past have done this
during the last pandemic during aids we
again saw
a bloodborne pathogen that just was
totally sweeping
hospitals and healthcare institutions
all across the country
and we intervened and put a clock on
osha
to develop a bloodborne pathogen
workforce standard and that's why today
when you go to the hospitals
people are wearing gloves they're using
disposable needles
all that stuff that we take for granted
now that was osha
and actually it was congress who told
osha to develop that standard
so we're in a situation here today in
2021 where again
we're seeing something out there that
again i
and i want to thank miss fox i mean
because she's not in denial
that's for sure i mean she really as i
said thoughtfully
talked about what's what's driving some
of this but the fact is
now it's time to act and and and again i
want to thank again some of the
republican
members who came forward because i think
you know they they
it's hard you know right now but they
came forward and co-sponsored this bill
and i hope
madam speaker that you know the
experience again the shared experience
of the last year that this country went
through
is something people will think about
when they vote um
later today and support this legislation
and without a yield back
gentleman yields back all time for
debate has expired
each further amendment printed in
section c of house report
117-15 not earlier considered as part of
an amendment's end block
pursuant to section 6 of house
resolution 303
shall be considered only in the order
printed in the report
may be offered only by a member
designated in the report
shall be considered as read shall be
debatable for the time specified in the
report equally divided and controlled
by the proponent and an opponent may be
withdrawn by the proponent at any time
before the question
is put thereon shall not be subject to
amendment and shall not be subject to a
demand
for division of the question it shall be
in order at any time for the chair of
the committee on education and labor
or his design to offer amendments and
block consisting of further amendments
printed in section c of house report
117-15
not earlier disposed of amendments and
blocks shall be considered as read
shall be debatable for 20 minutes
equally divided and controlled by the
chair and ranking member
of the committee on education and labor
on their respective
or their respective designees shall not
be subject to amendment
and shall not be subject to a demand for
division
of the question
for what purpose does the gentleman from
connecticut seek recognition
thank you madam speaker madam speaker as
the designee of the chairman of the
education and labor committee and
pursuant to section six of house
resolution 303 i rise to offer
amendments
on block number one the clerk shall
designate the amendments and block
on block number one consisting of
amendments numbered
one two three four and six print it in
part c
of house report number 117-15 offered by
mr courtney of connecticut
pursuant to house resolution 303 the
gentleman from connecticut
mr courtney and the gentlewoman from
north carolina miss
fox each will control 10 minutes the
chair recognizes the gentleman from
connecticut
thank you madam speaker madam speaker i
rise in support of an on block amendment
number one these five amendments will
one direct osha to prioritize providing
technical assistance
and advice to employers to promote
compliance with during the first year
two clarify that nothing in this act
will limit existing protections against
domestic violence stalking or sexual
violence
three clarified that employers can
consult experts when developing their
workplace violence prevention plans
four provide additional training to
workers who interact with survivors of
torture trafficking and domestic
violence
and five adds alzheimer's and memory
care facilities
as facilities covered by this
legislation these amendments make
meaningful improvements to the bill and
i urge a yes vote
on on block number one and i now yield
one minute